bergeron le secrétaire national du parti
communiste français est l'invité cette
semaine de preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous pour large
balayage de tous les sujets politiques
du moment l'action de françois hollande
et de son gouvernement que vous
combattez tout en vous alliant à paris
avec la socialiste anne hidalgo l'avenir
du front de gauche est votre relation
personnelle au point mort avec jean luc
mélenchon
quel est le prix jean de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire avec
dailymotion et perrine tarneaud de
public sénat
nous rejoindrons tour à tour d'abord
pierre laurent jean marc ayrault a à
nouveau défendu ce mardi
l'humanité de la proposition qui était
faite par le chef de l'état à léonard da
alors que le pcf a dénoncé très vite
l'inhumanité de cette proposition et
même l'image est noté a titré sur un
chantage inhumain est ce que vous
comptez sur la mobilisation lycéenne
pour faire fléchir le gouvernement en
faveur de toute sa famille écoutez beau
ce moment les lycéens les lycéens seront
en vacances mais ce qui est certain sur
cette affaire c'est que on ne peut pas
demander à une enfant de 15 ans ne
choisir entre la france et sa famille
donc soit on fait le choix de la faire
rentrer avec sa famille
mais on ne peut pas la mettre devant un
chantage de ce type qui qui qui l'a mais
personnellement dans une situation
impossible
enfin je crois parce que on demande à
une enfant de 15 ans de faire un choix
impossible de faire un choix impossible
d'examiner loin puisqu'elle dit et pour
cause puisque on la met devant une
situation impossible
donc manifestement devant devant le
doute ou moi je n'ai pas parlé
personnellement avec elle mais je crois
que ce qui est dramatique dans cette
affaire c'est que nous avons en france
des lycéens des collégiens des lycéens
même d'aider des enfants plus jeunes qui
sont scolarisés dans notre pays qui sont
parfois depuis plusieurs années ici qui
ont commencé à poursuivre des études qui
maîtrise notre langue et ce sera un gage
de confiance de la france que de les
aider à poursuivre leurs études en
france est d'aider leur famille à
s'installer dans notre pays on ne
comprend pas dans l'attitude du
gouvernement dans l'attitude du ministre
de l'intérieur et je ne parle pas des
déclarations la droite et de l'extrême
droite pourquoi on a peur de cette
situation alors qu'en fait je crois que
ce serait je le répète le c'est le signe
d'une confiance de la france en
elle-même que d'accueillir ces enfants
scolarisés à la fin mai ce sont les
familles qui réclamaient une immigration
économique on pensait que le pays a les
moyens encore aujourd'hui mais je crois
que nous sommes nous sommes dans un
monde où il va y avoir des migrations
des gens qui se déplacent des gens qui
vont qui vivent dans un pays qui vont
aller vivre dans un an et accompagner
les poids légers mais je crois que nous
avons la france a eu les moyens a
toujours eu les moyens et c'est très
bien accueillir et c'est très bien
organiser la solidarité celle de l'état
mais pas seulement
on sait que dans les quartiers cette
solidarité s'organise
rsf à sa manière le montre donc la
france est capable il rêve d'accueillir
ils sont capables de s'intégrer je
reprends pas seulement la formulation de
manuel valls vous allez pouvoir revenir
sur le cas du ministre l'intérieur mais
je reviens sur le cas de la famille
d'ibra rni qui est quand même
sérieusement épargné par le rapport de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration entre leur fils travail
et du père par exemple et puis
l'absentéisme scolaire des enfants de
tous leurs enfants
oui mais il y a mais on est au met en
exergue et c'est ça qui est dramatique
dans cette situation une famille mais on
sait très bien que la politique la
politique
du gouvernement qui est défendue par
manuel valls procède comme celle qui l'a
précédée avec un objectif de chiffre
donc il faut expulser 18000 vingt mille
personnes par an et on ne s'occupe pas
de cette question là alors qu'en vérité
on sait très bien que ça n'est pas une
difficulté pour la france de faire ça et
on pourrait très bien accueillir
accueillir ces familles moi je crois que
ce qui est inquiétant situation actuelle
c'est qu'en fait oui je pense et je vois
dans la situation actuelle on voit bien
qu'il ya une saturation autour de ces
questions qu on combine une exaspération
de l'opinion de langue mais qui met en
avant également salle curation mai
organisée par des responsables
politiques pour nous détourner de la des
vrais des vraies causes de la crise la
crise actuelle qui met beaucoup de jouer
entre autres la crise actuelle maîtrise
actuelle oui il met en scène il l'a fait
avec les rom il met en scène des des
problèmes de ce type pour masquer que ce
qui pose problème à la france ce qui
fait qu'il y a des millions de gens au
chômage ce qui provoque la division des
travailleurs dans ce pays ça une origine
ça s'appelle le pouvoir de la finance
il y a des gens qui passent leur temps à
organiser le licenciement la précarité
pour des objectifs de rentabilité et qui
s'enrichissent derrière et on ne veut
plus modeste débat dans le pays alors
que c'était le débat central au moment
de la présidentielle
ayrault absolument absolument on désigne
les roms comme des boucs émissaires
alors qu'en vérité il y à des millions
de gens qui souffrent dans ce pays parce
que la finance organise le licenciement
de leurs familles alors si je vous
comprends bien faire le rang ou dit il
faut arrêter toutes les expulsions
d'enfants scolarisés oui d'accord donc
ça veut dire qu'on cesse d'expulser
toutes ces familles tout à leur famille
ton leur part en situation irrégulière
oui je pense qu'il faut régulariser à
tout le monde
écoutez mais c'est une proposition que
nous faisons je pense que cela aurait vu
la socialement mais d'ailleurs là
le fait qu'il y ait en france des gens
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient sans papiers
qui soit dans cette situation est un
problème pour tous les travailleurs
parce que ces gens là sont exploités
avec leur situation son papier pour
mettre en concurrence des travailleurs
entre eux et si on régularise s est
travailleur et bien et d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'avait très bien montré la grève
des travailleurs sans papiers qui a duré
si longtemps en ile de france on avait
vu à ce moment-là surgir de beaucoup
d'entreprises des travailleurs
invisibles qui sont en fait comment
employer par des patrons qui ont pignon
sur rue qui sont des gens extrêmement
connus qui sont des grands groupes et
qui se font de l'argent sur ces pauvres
jouanno
si on comprend bien on avait dix corps
est clair un perdant et si je reprends
ce qu'a dit jean pierre chevènement vous
êtes un sans-papier rist 1 sans
frontières east
oui mais où ai je suis un
internationaliste je suis communiste
internationaliste et ça depuis longtemps
mais ce que je veux surtout c'est que
les gens qui m'écoutent comprennent une
chose ce dont on veut ce qu'on essaye de
masquer dans la situation c'est qu'il ya
50 milliards d'euros d'évasion fiscale
il ya 170 milliards d'euros de cadeaux
fiscaux d'exonérations de cotisations
sociales
il ya des gens qui continuent à s'en
plein la poche on vient nous
parler il ya quelques temps du du
travail du dimanche on a oublié nous
dire une chose c'est que le propriétaire
de ces magasins qui veulent ouvrir le
dimanche c'est la famille mulliez est
une des familles les plus riches de
notre pays et qui sont enrichis toutes
ces dernières années et cette cause
profonde de la crise on veut évacuer
cette question du débat moi je pense que
la france a les moyens
la fin de la france a les moyens de son
développement à condition de cesser de
se faire racketter par le pouvoir de la
finance
et c'est ça le vrai problème et c'est
pas la situation de travailleurs
immigrés qui sont eux aussi des victimes
de la misère la france et racketté oui
elle est inquiété par les prélèvements
financiers par des frais bancaires
exagéré parce qu'ils refusent de payer
leurs impôts
les grands groupes de quatre 4 ans et 10
qui sont récupérés mais les grands
groupes du cac40 ça c'est des rapports
officiels qu'ils disent ils payent en
moyenne 8 % d'impôt quand le taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés est
officiellement de 33 pour sow alors
ouais pas répondu tout à l'heure sur la
mobilisation des collégiens des lycéens
est ce qu'elle doit continuer vont
l'encourager et je crois que la jeunesse
et mobilisés spontanément parce qu'elle
n'accepte pas cette situation
mais si les soutenait mais bien sûr les
jeunes de quant à leur manière ont
essayé de réveiller les valeurs qui font
la france parce que la solidarité la
fraternité ça fait partie des valeurs de
la république et ça se vit au quotidien
et c'est ces jeunes lycéens qui ont
manifesté spontanément ne comprennent
pas ce qui se passe parce que ils voient
des copains à eux être expulsé du jour
au lendemain alors qu'ils vivent à leurs
côtés depuis des années sans aucun
problème on leur dit ils sont en
vacances à la toussaint pour l'instant
un combat continue oui bien sûr le
combat le combat continue et pas
seulement à la rentrée des vacances mais
pour plus longtemps parce qu il y aura
une manifestation il ya ma nation qui a
lancé le 5 novembre vont la soutenait
bien sûr bien sûr et si je peux y être
j'y serai je sais pas si je pourrai y
être mais si je peux y être j'y serai là
vous y serez entre les gangs 5l le
pouvoir est assez effrayés par une
manifestation des lycéens est sûre mais
sympa comme le lait sur le feu
on est allé en continu est belle les
gens qui ont peur de la jeunesse c'est
toujours inquiétant parce que c'est une
preuve de manque de confiance de loisirs
droite gauche oui parce que lorsque au
lieu de faire des grands discours
démagogiques sur la jeunesse il ferait
mieux d'écouter la jeunesse ont la
jeunesse dit on le cur hausse
arrêtons ces expulsions et à la bière
raison je pense que vous avez encore des
choses à dire sur manuel valls 1 on
l'avait cité déjà plusieurs fois début
de cette émission pour beaucoup on même
s'il est contesté on le sait au sein du
parti social mais pour beaucoup
notamment des élus socialistes qui se
présente aux municipales
c'est lui le seul rempart face au front
national lui qui le plus utile
aujourd'hui à la gauche
et ce n'est pas le départ on part il
fait partie de ceux qui aujourd'hui
banalise des idées qui nourrissent la
montée de la droite il
du front national parce que en plus il
fait des discours mais il n'agit pas
parce que quand il ya des collectivités
locales qui sont confrontés par exemple
aux problèmes de deux villages de rome
qui ne peuvent pas rester dans ces
conditions qui sont quasiment des
bidonvilles et bien où est l'aide du
ministre de l'intérieur pour travailler
avec ces collectivités locales ou de
travailler avec ses co les communautés
locales que fait-il concrètement pour
régler le problème
où est la table ronde que nous demandons
depuis des mois avec les maires de ces
villes a travaillé nationale à maurice
du discours du front national il
banalise effectivement des idées qui
sont des idées d'exclusion quand il dit
que des populations nous ne n'arrive
rompt jamais à s'intégrer eh bien ce
n'est pas un discours de gauche et
d'ailleurs manuel valls n'a jamais été
le grand représentant de la gauche je
rappelle que même dans la primaire
socialiste il avait fait 5 % des voix
donc ça veut dire que chez les militants
socialistes il n'est pas considéré que
le grand porteur d'une même politique de
gauche mais ce qui est inquiétant dans
la situation actuelle c'est que il
semble faire la pluie et le beau temps
sur un certain nombre de décisions de
l'elysée alors que l'elysée devrait
écouter davantage ses électeurs et vous
considérez donc analyser un problème
d'autorité face à manuel valls
mais il a un problème surtout de cap de
cap politique de cap à gauche c'est à
dire qu'il a l'autorité von est un
problème de temps et 1 semaine lorsqu'il
impose au chef de l'état
on a l'impression que qui gouverne ce
pays on a l'impression qu'en matière
économique c'est davantage les marchés
financiers les grands groupes que le
pouvoir le pouvoir socialiste
en fonction de ce qu'il avait annoncé
aux électeurs en là en l'occurrence on
al impression qu effectivement manuel
valls a plus d'importance que tous les
socialistes que j'ai entendu condamné
l'expulsion leonarda donc il y a
effectivement un problème
où est le centre de gravité de la
politique qui est menée aujourd'hui par
le pouvoir socialiste
la meilleure façon de rétablir ce sans
gravité pour vous ce serait le départ de
manuel valls n'est gouvernement se
serait de ce ça peut en faire partie il
faut changer de toute façon moi je
compte sur lui
sa politique devront changer parce que
moi j'appelle un changement de cap de
l'ensemble de la politique
gouvernementale
donc ça passera par un changement
d'équipage et la question elle est plus
global que celle de manuel valls
malheureusement les chargements avec
quelqu'un catane et non une mesure forte
symbolique qui permettrait de vous faire
entrer dans la majorité présidentielle
je les dis tout net mais je l ai dit
tout à l'heure il faut par exemple
remettre la main sur les landes riches
ces vagues ne sais pas s'il va que ça on
avait promis prenons une mesure précise
on avait promis une grande réforme de
justice fiscale
et bien non seulement elle n'a pas lieu
mais on à linverse on a augmentation de
la tva augmentation des taxes sur les
salariés et exonérations croissante
eh bien il faut faire exactement la dîme
aller chercher l'argent du côté du
canada je tiens à rien j'ai dit sur les
faux ménages oui il faut mais néanmoins
agir et 15000 à s'agit d'entreprises
gg préposé au front de gauche de mener
une campagne sur le coût du capital
parce que le problème de ce pays n'est
pas le coût du travail c'est le coût du
capital or en vendée un changement de
cap économique c'est clair mais
politique
mais réclame un vote de confiance car la
majorité exposants mais aussi un vote de
confiance vont à l'école et la
dissolution de la droite la droite elle
fait de la démagogie
alors qu'en vérité quand je les écoute
combattre soit disant les mesures du
gouvernement c'est toujours pour en
demander plus
dont le sens des exonérations pour le
capital donc c'est pas avec le retour de
la droite qu'on va sortir de cette
situation
la seule possibilité d'en sortir de
bonnes manières c'est effectivement
d'obtenir un cap sérieux une
réorientation complète de la politique
vers la gauche c'est à dire vers ce
qu'attendait ceux qui ont porté françois
hollande au pouvoir et pour y parvenir
je pense qu'il faut leur mobilisation
sociale et elles ne sont pas suffisantes
aujourd'hui mais ça peut revenir il faut
leur mobilisation sociale il faut leur
mobilisation électorale dans les
prochaines échéances municipales et
européennes
un mot sur l'ump qui veut remettre en
cause le droit du sol dans notre pays
ont manifestement en mettant fin à
l'acquisition automatique de la
nationalité pour les enfants sont nés en
france mais de parents en situation
irrégulière qu'un pan des bureaux à
sanaa on voit bien que bon c'est une
c'est une déclaration copé pour
continuer toujours pareil à aller
chasser ou un courir derrière le dépôt
derrière le front national mais surtout
surtout ce sont des propositions
qu'elles viennent de la droite du front
national de gens qui n'ont plus
confiance dans la france qui ne croit
plus en ce pays qui ne croit plus en ses
valeurs ce sont des gens qui ont perdu
confiance dans la france et dans sa
capacité à développer sa jeunesse à
accueillir des c'est même pas accueillir
puisque là on parle d'enfants qui sont
nés dans notre pays sur notre sol et qui
devraient pouvoir automatiquement
acquérir la naissance de leur deuxième
choix
chose non il suffirait tout simplement
comme ça comme c'était le cas avant des
îles ce nom il suffirait comme c'était
le cas avant que né en france
ils deviennent français ils peuvent
garder aussi l'ordre la nationalité de
leurs parents et ça c'était comme ça
pendant des décennies on n'est pas
obligé de revenir sur ça allez on va
évoquer maintenant les municipales ah et
puis l'exception parisienne
jean luc mélenchon dénonce un cas
déplorable votre alliance dès le premier
tour avec la socialiste anne hidalgo qui
va tenter de succéder à bertrand delanoë
alors est ce que vous auriez troquer
votre indépendance de jugement vient
d'entendre tout aux critiques il y en
aura encore d'autres d'ici la fin de
cette émission contre 13 postes de
conseillers de paris avant d'accueillir
cathay le prix jean de l' agence
france-presse
le reportage mais faustine saint geniès
ils sont unis et tiennent à le montrer
avec cette photo de famille bien
orchestré les communistes ont voté pour
une liste avec le ps dès le premier tour
des municipales
comme en 2001 et 2008 à l'hidalgo est
aux anges
nous nous sommes reconnus nous nous
sommes retrouvés à la fois sur un bilan
mais aussi sur une ambition et sur une
méthode pour continuer à transformer
paris un accord qui n'avait pourtant
rien d'évident
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
le pcf et le front de gauche se montrent
très critiques envers le gouvernement
c'est donc une rupture avec cette
stratégie ian brossât chef de file des
communistes parisiens intègre même
l'équipe de campagne d'hamid algo mais
il veut tout de même rassuré ses anciens
alliés
le front gauche continue continuera et
je crois qu'il ne faut pas comment dire
dramatiser l'enjeu autour d'une
différence d'appréciation sur les
élections municipales à paris dans les
bureaux de vote certains militants
communistes juge cette décision
incohérente et d'hôpitaux front de
gauche ont voté contre le budget
l'assemblée nationale et ils ont raison
de le faire ou de la politique de
françois hollande est donc tout ça ça va
nous ça va nous faire apparaître comme
comme il n'y a aucune stratégie propre
indépendante
l'accord électoral reprend certaines
propositions cher aux communistes 30 %
de logements sociaux d'ici 2030 à paris
ou encore la gratuité des premiers
mètres cubes d'eau sous condition de
ressources mais c'est aussi un accord
tactique en cas de victoire le pc n'aura
plus 8 mai 13 postes de conseillers de
paris indispensable pour que pierre
laurent reste sénateur dans la capitale
un accord au rabais pour certains
militants
je pense que tout un tas de personnes
qui sont déçus de la politique de
françois hollande attendent une
alternative et moi j'ai envie qu'on leur
propose cette alternative à paris avec
un front gauche vaquer à des gels
proposition l'accord parisien devrait
rester une exception
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espèrent les
autres composantes du front de gauche
voilà quatre questions nationales alors
on l'a vu cette alliance à paris des
boussoles des membres des militants du
pc mais aussi des membres du front de
gauche y en a un qui est
particulièrement déboussolé c'est jean
luc mélenchon il se dit avoir le coeur
en cendres est personnellement et
odieusement trail est ce que vous avez
odieusement trahi jean luc mélenchon
nous avons un cap qui est simple
finalement qui est très simple pour les
élections municipales c'est nous
contestons la polluent la politique du
gouvernement parce qu'elle n'est pas une
politique de bush
eh bien nous voulons dans les communes
pouvoir mener des politiques de bush
donc nous travaillons à cela là où il
existe des majorités de gauche là où
nous voudrions les conquérir et on
essaye de le faire au rassemblant le
plus largement possible et quand c'est
quand les conditions sont créées pour le
faire avec des socialistes qui acceptent
des objectifs de gauche et bien nous le
faisons comme appareil et donc il n'y a
aucune volonté de se détourner de la
stratégie du front de gauche là dedans
il ya une application dans la bataille
municipale de 7,2 cette stratégie-là au
tenant compte des rapports de force
locaux alors évidemment ça provoque du
débat chez nous même chez les
communistes
c'est normal mais pourquoi mais pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que vous voudriez qu'il
en soit autrement
on a une politique gouvernementale qui
est désastreuse et qui est prétendument
donné au nom de la gauche
donc il ya des gens qui sont déboussolés
par cette situation et nous nous disons
dans les élections municipales
on va pas abandonner le combat pour
autant c'est étonnant célarié symbolique
vous allez faire la fenêtre sous les
sous sous les projecteurs et là mais
vous êtes associés au ps et vous allez
vous retrouver face au pg qui plaisent
en tunise mais ce qui est symbolique en
ce moment à paris c'est qu'effectivement
dans la capitale de la france la gauche
est en transe engagé à dire en tout cas
la liste dans laquelle nous allons aller
nous allons faire 30 % de logements
sociaux alors qu'on vient à peine
d'atteindre 20%
nous allons continuer à construire
encore plus de crèches que nous l'avons
fait alors que le gouvernement lui dis
moi je vais réduire de 3 milliards et
demi le budget de la sécurité sociale
qu'à paris vendredi dernier
anne hidalgo a dit sur la sphère
leonarda exactement la même chose que
moi et que mes camarades communistes
parisiens donc effectivement il ya une
singularité dans la situation parisienne
c'est que les forces du parti communiste
du parti socialiste s'engage en ce
moment à mener une politique de haut je
ne suis pas naïf je sais bien que ça
sera un combat
y compris avec avec les socialistes et
ça nous avait laissés
nous avons des points de désaccord sur
certains points aussi et dans les
mandats précédents nous avons eu des
débats y compris dans la majorité
municipale mais nous avons réussi à
faire progresser les choses vers une
politique de gauche et je pense que nous
sommes en train d'en créer les
conditions grâce à la manière dont les
communismes de la bataille à paris donc
nous nous tournons pas le dos au front
gauche loin s'en faut
nous essayons lui donner des atouts
supplémentaires s'affairent les marchés
car elle vient de rappeler il va y avoir
une candidate du parti de gauche qui va
même prendre l'ansej front de gauche à
paris
mais mais nous aussi nous sommes dans le
front gauche qui va y avoir une fusion
non il va pas y avoir de confusion il ya
un débat qui est transparent qui est sur
la table les électeurs sont majeurs ils
entendent les arguments que nous
mettrons sur la table les arguments que
d'autres mettent sur la table
ils feront leur choix ce sera la
démocratie et j'ai dit que vous avez
quitté le front de gauche en vous
alliant ps sur paris mais google que
j'ai quitté frau qui a fait 4 oh ça fait
quatre ans que jour et nuit que jour et
nuit
je m'occupe de développer le front de
gauche je vais pas comme ça du jour au
triangle carré alors que je pense alors
que je pense que la politique
gouvernementale est très mauvaise et qui
va falloir continuer à travailler à une
alternative à ce gouvernement et à sa
politique
donc c'est pas moi qui vais quitter le
front de gauche après tout ce que j'ai
fait pour le développer donc c'est
ridicule cette idée là je par contre
effectivement je veux que dans la
bataille municipale
on engrange tout ce qu'il est possible y
compris pour se donner de la force pour
mener la campagne nationale contre la
sonal est-ce que c'est très lisible que
vous soyez associés au ps à paris et
face au ps dans d'autres grandes villes
et bien c'est mais parce que vous
regardez la situation à marseille
vous croyez qu'elle est la même qu'à
paris monsieur mais il s'agit conquérir
il s'agit de conquérir la ville contre
la droite avec un danger de front
national et regarder le spectacle
désolant que donne la primaire
socialiste donc effectivement à
marseille nous nous y prenons autrement
mais nous avons le même objectif
nous nous y prenons trois mots parce
qu'à marseille s'il n'y a pas une force
comme la nôtre qui à l'initiative du
front de gauche 10 aux marseillais
vous voulez pas de ce spectacle
politique vous voulez une gauche digne
et une gauche qui s'occupe de vos
problèmes et pas de la guerre des égos
entre des candidats à la primaire eh
bien nous nous allons construire ses
listes aulas donc effectivement il ya
des villes où on s'y prend pas de la
même manière mais l'objectif est pour
moi exactement le même apparemment c'est
pas si clair que ça pour jean luc
mélenchon et est-ce que ça risque pas de
faire éclater le front de gauche toutes
ces bisbilles
évidemment je souhaite de tout mon coeur
qu'il n'en soit pas ainsi nous avoir d
un débat avec jean luc mélenchon sur ce
point mais moi je lui dis et je le redis
aujourd'hui
ce débat ne justifie pas loin s'en faut
un quelconque éclatement du front de
gauche nous avons eu d'autres aux débats
depuis le début du front de gauche et
nous avons continué a franchi à franchir
les étapes ensemble pour le moment ce
que je constate c'est que la majorité
des organisations du front de gauche 10
la très grande majorité la
quasi-totalité 10 effectivement nous
avons un débat sur les municipales dans
certaines villes mais ça ne justifie pas
de mettre en cause l'avenir du front
gauche c'est aussi ce que je dis avec
mes camarades communistes
donc il faut qu'on surmonte ce débat
qu'on l'assument
et puis qu'on continue à travailler
ensemble et on a une très bonne occasion
de le faire parce qu'il ya des élections
européennes quasiment en même temps
et là nous avons une ligne claire qui
nous rassemble tous
on vient moi je suis président du parti
de la gauche européenne de désigner
comme candidat commun pour nous être ne
porte parole au niveau de l'europe
alexis tsipras ski et les leaders de
syriza en grèce nous avons très bonne
occasion de mener logiquement toujours
sur les européennes
d'ailleurs il dit qu'il n'a plus aucun
contact avec vous sur les européennes
depuis le mois de juin qui est
primordial au club il ya une réunion qui
se tient tous les lundi matins
on continue de se tenir à la
coordination nationale du front san jose
à laquelle non c'est pas vrai moi j'y
participe très régulièrement par lui et
pas ces dernières semaines mais à cette
réunion nous discutons toute cette
question et il est prévu que le quai
lundi 4 novembre puisque ça a lieu tous
les lundis nous allons avoir une
discussion sur les futures élections
européennes dont nous commençons débat
vous et chez nous publions et nous
publions demain une déclaration de notre
comité exécutif national du parti
communiste qui dit il faut maintenant
aller vite dans la constitution des
listes aux élections européennes et être
prêt à la fin de l'année pour mener les
deux batailles au commun celle des
municipales et celles dans l'impression
un peu du poil de la bête face à jean
luc mélenchon cri très joli présent j'ai
l'impression de ne pas avoir déplacé les
médias qui raconte ça mais moi j'ai
toujours joué mon rôle dans le front de
gauche
j'ai toujours eu ma place et j'ai jamais
fait de complexe
en quoi que ce soit dans la conduite du
front de gauche donc jean luc mélenchon
à lui développé un complexe de
supériorité
non je ne crois pas nous à nous avons
mené une bataille très belle bataille
commune ensemble dans l'élection
présidentielle mais je pense que nous
sommes des forces différentes unis dans
un front mais différente
il ya des débats politiques il n'y a
aucune raison de dramatiser cdma polipa
sur les municipales c'est pas plus
profond que ça c'est aussi un débat sur
l'avenir du front de gauche sur une
vision chacun qui n'est pas forcément la
même sur ce que doit devenir le front de
gauche je crois qu'il ya un débat
sérieux oui sur qu'est ce qu'elle est
nous sommes dans une nouvelle situation
politique depuis la victoire de françois
hollande
et à partir du moment où on voit bien
que le gouvernement tourne le dos à ce
qui aurait dû être une politique de
gauche
nous avons un défi politique nouveau à
remplir parce que pour nous maintenant
il s'agit pas seulement de réunir ceux
qui ont voté front gauche il faut qu'on
se tourne vers des millions de gens qui
ont voté françois hollande et qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans la politique
gouvernementale
donc comment est-ce qu'on résout ce
problème comment est ce qu'on fait ça
provoque effectivement un débat nouveau
dans le front de gauche qui n'existait
pas avant
et on a des différends sur la manière
dont on aborde cette question pour moi
ces différences ne justifie sûrement pas
l'éclatement du front gauche parce que
de toute façon nous sommes condamnés à
relever ce défi politique parce que
c'est la seule manière d'empêcher le
retour de la droite voire le progrès de
l'extrême droite c'est de recréer un
espoir à gauche
au moment où le gouvernement lui tourne
pas mal justement dans une année
électorale municipale européenne et au
final on se rend compte sur les
élections intermédiaires c'est pas le
front de gauche c'est plutôt
effectivement le fn qui récupère les
voies les voix des migrants mais
actuellement actuellement ce qui se
passe et qui a un double phénomène
il ya un phénomène de démobilisation à
gauche à cause de la politique
gouvernementale
il ya un phénomène de radicalisation à
droite au faveur de l'extrême droite
mais parce que
l'ump a ouvert les vannes et on le voit
bien avec copé sur le droit du sol qui
valeurs mêmes manuels mais si vous-même
valcy et recréer l'espoir mais si nous
recréons l'espoir à gauche et il faut le
faire avec le front gauche et bien nous
pouvons résoudre cette question parce
que les gens qui ont voulu le changement
en 2012 n'ont ni abandonner leur valeur
ni abandonner leurs attentes ni
abandonner leurs espoirs
alors on a tout reste au possible avec
le front on a vu votre camarade de tout
à l'heure dans le sujet de faustine sa
jeunesse ian brossât qui est le porte
parole du pc et qui deviendra le porte
parole de la socialiste anne hidalgo a
paris il a poussé avec le porte parole
ed des communistes dans l'accompagnement
façon quoi ici on réduit pour pour paris
et il a poussé pour un voeux de la
municipalité avec bertrand de l'année
pour en faveur des roms et on se
souvient qu'il a demandé un village
d'insertion dans le 16e arrondissement
mais le maire lui a promis un retour
d'accorder aux roms
les logements vides de la ville de paris
c'est une bonne idée mais je crois que
vous savez le procès sur le problème des
roms mais sur cette question souvent
cité mais sur la wii mais parce que sur
le problème des roms ceux qui n'ont que
c'est tout simplement c'est une
politique d'accueil nationale qui parce
qu'on parle de 7 à 18 milles personnes
pour la france est largement impacter
sur 10 ans ce qu'est ce que vous dites
aux habitants de la région parisienne
qui attendent depuis des années un
logement social et les rênes mais nous
nous y sommes venus nous sommes c'est
pas à nous qu'il faut dire ça nous nous
battons depuis depuis deux mandats pour
mettre à la question la construction des
logements sociaux au premier rang des
priorités de la ville et nous l'avons
obtenu et nous obtenons que maintenant
ses objectifs soit amplifiée 11% dit que
la droite tandis que la droite appareils
par exemple se bat contre le moindre le
joueur social qui doit être construit
dès qu'ils ont un projet de logement
social que veut faire la ville de paris
dans le xvième ils font des recours à
n'en plus finir pour empêcher la
construction de ces logements sociaux
c'est quand même pas eux qui vont venir
nous donner des leçons sur la politique
de logement social appareils allez merci
ktm en vainqueur perrine tarneaud de
public sénat maintenant pour la
troisième partie d'émission
inari pour évoquer donc d'autres
réformes qui n'ont pas l'air de vous
plaire on a déjà bien entendu depuis le
début de cette émission mais on va
d'abord voir comment votre base sociale
et électorales et je fais des
propositions c'est inattendu contre la
finance particulier absolue on va voir
comment votre base est grignotée par le
front national justement qui parmi ces
villes cibles désignées pour les
prochaines municipales notamment retenu
des communes qui sont gérés de longue
date par le parti communiste français
c'est l'exemple par exemple de mitry
mory en seine-et-marne qu'a choisi marie
brémaud mitry mory commune
alors nous avons un problème est que
sujet qui m'est pas partie correctement
nous avons compris que nous étions à
mitry-mory avec marie brémaud une ville
gérée par le parti communiste depuis des
années et qu'il vise le front national
je pense que maintenant nous allons
pouvoir regarder non alors c'est vrai
qu'à une note la semaine dernière des
services du ministère de l'intérieur qui
alerté sur une société de plus en plus
inflammable
une colère qui une colère qui s'exprime
non pas dans la rue mais dans les urnes
est-ce que petit à petit le front
national grignote ces voix populaire
mais écoutez il ya une situation du pays
qui est très inquiétante et c'est le
résultat de quoi de dix ans de politique
de droite qui ont multiplié le chômage
la précarité la pauvreté qui ont cassé
les solidarités qui les ont cassé
concrètement et qui les ont cassé dans
les têtes en développant des idées
d'égoïsme de repli de xénophobie
et puis maintenant une politique de
gauche est maintenant dans une politique
socialiste du gouvernement socialiste
qui au lieu de prendre le taureau par
les cornes et de faire ce qui était
promis c'est à dire on va s'attaquer au
pouvoir de la finance on va mieux
répartir les richesses
on va faire de la solidarité fait le
contraire donc il ya un moment où les
gens se disent alors il n'y a plus rien
à faire donc il faut à ce moment là que
des forces se lève et c'est ce que nous
faisons pour organiser justement cette
solidarité pour montrer qu'il est
possible de mener des petites élèves
parce que vous avez du mal à avoir des
gens dans la rue dans vos manifestations
on a l'impression que la classe
politique les syndicalistes sont
impuissants qui coûtait 20 jours ccss
connaissent cesco c'est ce qu'on passe
son temps à c'est ce qu'on répète en
permanence pour évacuer le débat sur les
responsabilités parce que on peut voter
demain matin un projet de loi pour
interdire les licenciements boursiers
quand nous étions dans l'opposition
socialistes communistes et verts nous
l'avons voté on sent pourquoi est ce
qu'on veut
par manque de courage politique voilà
tout simplement
mais il existe demain matin dès majorité
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat qui
peuvent voter ces lois là nous pouvons
très bien au lieu de faire une la
politique fiscale qu'on est entre enfer
on peut très bien mettre les moyens pour
aller chercher les 50 milliards
d'évasion fiscale on peut très bien
contrôler les fonds publics qu'on
distribue aux entreprises alors qu'ils
s'en servent pour licencier donc il ya
aucune raison ou ajouts je conteste
l'idée de l'intuition d'impuissance
politique contrairement à ce qu'on dit
aux gens et c'est une question qu'il
faut avoir le courage de s'attaquer au
pouvoir de la finance quand françois
hollande disait au bourget c'est il y à
un ennemi
eh bien il maintenant il faut le faire
du coup est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec jean luc mélenchon quand il dit que
finalement la politique du parti
socialiste est presque pire que celle de
l'ump
en tout cas c'est c'est pas une
politique de gauche là dessus moi je
peux aider dans certains domaines
elle est en train d'aggraver elle est en
train d'aggraver la situation voit avec
la réforme des retraites
on avait la réforme sarkozy on avait dit
on va la combattre
au lieu de la corriger on rallonge
encore les années de cotisations mais
quand même qu'on va s'arrêter structurel
cette réforme sur les retraites elle va
conduire à ce qu'on partira à nouveau
plus tard avec des retraites et des
pensions encore dégradée voilà le
résultat
parce qu'avec plus en compte la
pénibilité par exemple dans l elle dit
qu'elle prend en compte la pénibilité
mais quand on passe aux dispositifs
concrets de prise en compte de la
pénibilité on est à des kilomètres de ce
que demande aux organisations sociales
sur quatre ce qui aura un compte qu'un
humilité oui mais il y a des il y a des
îles y adhérer la seule chose nouvelle
c'est qu'on inscrit ce principe là dans
la loi mais pour ce qui est des
dispositifs concrets qui vont permettre
d'accéder à une véritable reconnaissance
de la pénibilité dans le projet de loi
on est très loin du compte
et d'ailleurs si le gouvernement veut
rendre ça plus concret il pourra très
bien reprendre nos amendements dans le
débat qui démarre lundi aussi le voir
parce qu'on va pas manquer d'amender le
projet sur cette question et sur la
question de la jeunesse sur la question
des retraites des femmes et sur beaucoup
d'autres questions quelque 400
amendements attendu
de votre groupe effectivement sur sur ce
projet de loi retraites vous confirmer
qu'au sénat vous ne voterez ni le projet
de loi sur les retraites ni le projet de
loi ni la loi de finances ni la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ne
voteront pas le projet de loi sur les
retraites elle qu'il nous arrive ça
c'est clair et net nous allons déposer
vous dit à peu près de 200 amendements
nous avions le groupe ce matin c'est à
peu près ça eh bien nous attendons que
ces amendements soir prince y ont des
6es comme à l'assemblée nationale on
nous retourne tous ses amendements nous
votre rencontre et sur le budget nouveau
trop content pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'on nous propose encore de nous
enfoncer dans une logique budgétaire qui
n'améliore pas la situation du pays ne
permet pas de croissance ne résout pas
les inégalités et en plus ne résout même
pas les déficits et ce à la sécurité
sociale c'est pareil on voit sera pas
non plus la prochaine loi ces maisons
parce que nous sommes toujours dans la
même logique
toujours dans la même logique qui
continue à faire des cadeaux toujours ou
même et à ne pas résoudre les problèmes
les problèmes d'inégalités sociales
nokia laurent savate logique mal à vous
comprendrez que peut-être les électeurs
français soit un peu perdus quand ils
vous voient nouer des alliances avec le
parti socialiste même sens pour des
élections locales mais on s'est expliqué
il parce que coop qui lie à une
politique gouvernementale
comprenez qu'il refuse assez du coût des
partis politiques français je mets du
temps des cygnes ou ce concert de 10 690
justement c'est exactement le contraire
en ce qui nous concerne c'est qu'on nous
demande de nous enfermer dans des
postures politiques politiciennes a
priori et nous nous disons exactement
contraire parce que nous mais parce que
notre boussole n'est pas celle que sur
laquelle vous m'interrogez en permanence
les alliances
moi ma boussole c est ce que ce qu'on
fait va être utile aux populations mas
et à paris csq rallu logement social
est-ce qu'on va lutter contre la
spéculation
est-ce qu'on va construire des crèches
pour répondre est-ce qu'on va est ce
qu'on va faire des transports publics
est sec il / elle est maintenant mais ça
depuis 2001 oui absolument
l'équipe de bertrand delanoë et grâce
justement au travail des communistes
dans cette majorité afin par exemple de
la construction de logement social une
de ses grandes priorités
je rappelle que quand au delà de la noé
à gagner la ville
en 2001 il y avait dans le programme de
delanoë l'idée de construire 3000
logements sociaux par pau nous nous en
propose ion plus à l'époque et
aujourd'hui on en construit cinq à six
mille par an grâce à la bataille que
nous avons menées et avec l'objectif qui
est retenu dans l'accord que vous nous
passez avec anne hidalgo
ce sera plus de 7000 logements sociaux
par an voilà ça c'est du concret et nous
c'est ce qui nous déterminent c'est pas
avec les alliances les postures et que
j'étais assez justement exactions
étaient à matignon alors là vous seriez
derrière elle ben si elle était à
matignon pour prendre cet exemple je
pense que cette hypothèse ne se ne se
présente pas mais si elle ou une autre
et disait je change totalement la
politique du gouvernement actuel pour
refaire une autre on discuterait le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand il
s'agit de discuter la politique
gouvernementale
du côté de des dirigeants actuels du
parti socialiste pour le moment il ya
personne pour dire on va faire ça et
donc nous ne pouvons pas prêter la main
à cette politique qui va dans le mur
mais quand dans une commune il est
possible d'avancer dans ce sens là et
bien nous nous saisissons l'occasion
parce que précisément ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce qui se passe pour les
jeunes arrivés par d'autres agriculteurs
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui contre le
projet d'écotaxe qui rentrera en vigueur
le 1er janvier 2014
est-ce qu'il faut la supprimer ou la
maintenir cette écotaxe les le problème
de cette écotaxe c'est qu'elle est elle
est une fois de plus elle est injuste
elle qu'elle est conçue par ce qu'elle
va frapper des jo au niveau de la
consommation alors qu'en vérité il
faudrait prendre le problème de
l'écologie en amont parce qu'il faut une
politique écologique mais il faut se
transporte apprécié de favoriser des
magouilles semences parce qu'ils soient
moins voyants ont le cul roos vous dit à
des gens nous vous donnons aucun moyen
de changer vos moyens de transport de
les renouveler parce que on sait que les
agriculteurs ont des problèmes de
revenus importants vous êtes obligés de
redoubler votre matériel et la seule
chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on vous taxe à
la rue si on veut que ils utilisent des
moyens des moyens
moins polluants et bien à ce moment là
on les aide à changer d'équipement ont
créé les conditions pour qu'il change
d'équipements aux finances des nouveaux
équipements et on aide les agriculteurs
à moderniser dans un sens écologique
leur matériel et leur mode de production
on s'attaque à la racine du problème
là on le fait pas on dit qu'on fait ça
on fait rien du tout mais on les laisse
dans la même difficulté et on les taxe à
la sortie après dix ans c'est le sait
mais même les verts sont sont ne sont
pas très contre 6,6 et défense assez
d'initiatives du grenelle que l'on
m'écoute et j'écoute ce que disent les
verts je discute beaucoup avec eux je
n'ai pas l'impression s'il saute de joie
avait attiré joie devant la politique
écologique du gouvernement
d'accord c'est donc taxi on n'arrête pas
de dire que cette politique écologique
n'est pas mais sans mener bataille n'est
pas il ya eu aussi des conditions sur
les contrats sur le scandale de
l'espionnage à services secrets
américains vers l'europe notamment la
france vous demander à ce que la france
sorte de l'otan mais ce que voulait
aussi qu'on mette fin à toute
coordination coopération de lutte contre
le terrorisme mais écouter mais qu'elle
est qu'elle est quel est le rapport
quel rapport est ce que vous payez que
si on espère tous les français qui
utilisent les communications des
communications téléphoniques on va
lutter contre le terrorisme et la france
notamment à la base il ya problème est
un problème très sérieux des rapports
entre la france et des états unis
surtout que cette affaire n'est pas la
première on en est déjà aux trois au
quatrième incident lourd quand même je
parle même pas de l'arrêt de l'avion
d'evo morales et et autres et autre
incident diplomatique
jusqu'à quand va se faire humilier par
un pays qui dit non à droite surveiller
tout le monde on fait ce qu'on veut
personne n'a le droit de nous demander
des comptes et puis non continue
d'accepter ça et on accepte de
s'intégrer dans le commandement
militaire intégré de l'otan sous
responsabilité des américains et on n'a
pas notre mot à dire
moi j'ai connu même à droite quand même
des dirigeants politiques qui avaient un
peu plus de dignité pour faire respecter
la parole de la france air quand j'en ai
fait remettre en cause notamment les
accords de libre échange
oui il faut non seulement il faut
remettre en cause ce qui existe mais il
faut surtout pas aller vers ce qu'on
nous propose en europe
le pacte transatlantique le traité
grand marché transatlantique qui
préconise de libéraliser tous les
échanges et qui va ouvrir en fait nos
marchés aux états unis sans aucune sans
aucune contrepartie d'alliance de
dignité demandez vous à laon la
dénomination l'état mais il a eu un
échange à vis à vis du temps avec marc
accos mars ils ont essayé sa réprobation
si la mollesse et la moindre des changes
comme un des cylindres de choses mais
puisque on commençait à la discussion
sur l'otan que je pense que nous
devrions développer une politique de la
france plus indépendante et qui n'attend
pas le feu vert des états unis pour
décider ce qu'elle fait dans telle ou
telle région question oui oh non c'est
vrai vous vous parlez plus du tout et
les gens avec mes enfants que sa cote et
vous n'avez pas répondu de salem et et
où on comprenait les juges avaient
publié même à la fête de l'humanité on a
à plusieurs reprises on sait la croisée
ensemble la fête de l'engrais de croiser
m'en vais vous parler on a compris qu'un
rendez vous était prévu au début du mois
de novembre
le 3 ou 4 le 4 novembre pour discuter
sur les élections européennes c'est bon
ça à ton s'est très vite
du coup